the
[Music]
country and molecules each living cell has
to be its own hard drive where it
stores all the information needed
to function in grow adapt to
environmental changes and fight which
includes the dangerous this information
is stored in molecules that are
organized in sequences  of letters
known as the DNA genetic code
of the 1990's tremendous effort by
governments researchers companies has resulted
in the complete sequence of the human genome
since then we have an
exponential growth of molecular data
describing cells tissues organs and
organisms very large data set
contains the  genetic information
about young healthy and sick old people
is now freely available to the
public here we are going to explore the
various types of omics data as well as
examples of information that it has
associated genomic variants
possibility levels of gene expression
who knows what is the spread of
cancer and  pr modifications  oteica that can
make important and readable code
this course is intended for anyone
interested in understanding how the current
biometric data revolution
impacts biomedical research and human health